ramène toutes les saveurs de la réunion
sur sur ce village nous aurons le temps
fort lundi notamment avec l'inauguration
du village réunion nous aurons plusieurs
événements nous aurons aussi cette
conférence de presse autour de deux lits
gp et me sont utiles mercredi pour 20
états membres mettre en avant et puis
nous attendrons aussi le résultats des
différents concours savoir si nous
aurons des médailles et cela ce sera
jeudi 3 mars que nous aurons donc on
l'espère de nombreux médaillés de l'île
de la réunion et de l'agriculture
réunionnaise
[Musique]
c
ah si
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de dire c'est tous les jours
un temps fort sur le stand et sur le
village réunion avec les animations avec
aussi notre chef cuisine qui va nous
préparer d'ailleurs aujourd'hui s'est
réchauffée avec la morue première petite
déception je disais que le contexte
national pèse un peu seul en dix ans du
salon malheureusement le président de la
république ne déroule pas cette année
dans dans le salon de l'agriculture il
est hélas très tôt ce matin pour une
rencontre avec les acteurs du monde
agricole français nous attendons cet
après midi la visite du premier ministre
également la visite du ministre de
l'outre-mer et puis bien sûr tous les
candidats qui viendront je le pense
visité les différents stands et
l'outre-mer ne pourra pas être mis de
côté ou oubliées d'habitude c'est tout
part pour certains ce sont ces un
passage furtif cette année je pense
qu'ils vont tous prendre le temps c'est
important parce que nous aurons
l'occasion je l'espère de pouvoir leur
expliquer nos spécificités nos
singularités de notre île de notre
agriculture pour qu'ils puissent s'y
prendre la mesure de cet enjeu du monde
agricole de la réunion je voudrais
terminer mes propos en remerciant du
fond du coeur l'ensemble de mes
collègues du conseil départemental et
bien sûr notre président cyrille
melchior qui qui nous font confiance qui
font confiance aussi aux équipes de
l'équipe du département l'équipe de la
direction de la culture qui travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour faire en sorte que
ce salon soit un salon grandiose pour
les réunionnaises et les réunionnais et
puis bien sûr j'invite celles et ceux
qui sont de la réunion qui sont soit en
ile de france ou en province de venir à
paris et de venir retrouver les saveurs
de lier la ligne